we deserve to have the same rights as
anybody does
it's been 13 years and it's enough
netflix dropped the 88 second trailer
today at noon pacific time
i've worked my whole life
i don't owe these people anything
hi my name is
earlier yesterday netflix posted this
chilling 18 second teaser for the doc a
2009 voicemail brit allegedly left for
an attorney i'm calling kim because i
just wanted to make sure
that we're in the process of entering
within 24 hours it already had one and a
half million views legal expert rachel
stockman says the audio is pretty
interesting considering britney
testified in court she did not know it
was possible to end her conservatorship
i don't think it necessarily means we
can pin britney spears as some kind of
liar in this situation because first of
all we don't have the whole context
exactly what the voicemail said
the doc called britney versus spears
premieres next tuesday that's the day
before britney's next big court hearing
this morning brittany's attorney filed
legal papers to end the conservatorship
this fall there is a potential we're
going to see quite a bit of movement at
this hearing
like all things brit the dot news is
stirring up conspiracy theories here's
one britney's constant cryptic posts
about red were really a nod to netflix
distinct logo and this project
[Music]